en 2017 mélanie lemay prend la parole
c'est une grande victoire parce que je
pensais pas vivre ça de mon vivant
autant de personnes qui viennent porter
et dénoncé le fait qu'elles ont eu la
violence mélanie comme des milliers
d'autres victimes partout dans le monde
dénonce l'agression sexuelle subie des
années auparavant
nous sommes en plein mouvement mis tout
nouvellement je suis fait piéger cet
esprit j'ai été sauvagement violées j'ai
pensé que j'ai à ce moment là que
j'allais mourir parce qu'ils essaient de
m'étrangler avec mes clips à justin
coleraine ce think tank ou eric s'il a
parfois
deux ans plus tard que reste-t-il de
cette vague de dénonciations qui a fait
tomber des géants de hollywood
à montréal on a une à de nouvelles
demandes par semaine juste un lieu de la
culture sophie gagnon est à la tête de
la partie un service de conseil
juridique pour les victimes du milieu
culturel mis en place dans la foulée du
mouvement
aujourd'hui la demande est toujours
forte et l'organisme s'apprête à étendre
ses services à tous les milieux de
travail
l'intention de la société à mon avis est
vraiment créer un changement culture ça
ça prend du temps
malgré des ressources plus accessibles
les deux dernières années ont été
difficiles pour les victimes qui se sont
adressées aux tribunaux
plusieurs dénonciations ne se sont pas
traduites par des accusations
le mouvement met beaucoup de sport pour
les femmes enfin j'aurais cru est
entendu par le système est beaucoup en
ce moment se heurte à des situations
leurs dossiers fermés
en l'absence d'une réforme du système de
justice réclamée par plusieurs
mélanie le mais déplore le manque de
volonté des politiciens à ottawa
je trouve ça vraiment collé matic en
même temps pas un acte orale le fait
qu'il ya eu un mouvement international
comme ça qu'ils aillent voir tellement
de discussions mais malgré tout ce soit
un enjeu central à la campagne un rendez
vous raté pour un mouvement dont on
entend moins parler mais qui peut se
réanimer à tout moment et si jacques
andré charbonneau radio canada mon frère